one of the ways that people can help is
by adding to the knowledge base and
that's really basically anybody if the
tooling is right
and um
the other way i kind of want to ask you
about your thoughts on this so you've
had like you said in government and
you have
big clients you had a lot of clients but
most of it is shrouded in secrecy
because of the nature of the
relationship of the kind of things
you're helping them with
so that's one way to operate and another
way to operate is more in the open
where it's more consumer facing
and so uh you know hence something like
open cycle is born at some point or
there's no that that's a misconception
oh oh well let's let's go there so what
all right uh what is open psych and how
was it born two things i want to say and
i want to say each of them before the
other so it's going to be difficult
but we'll come back to open psych in a
minute but one of the terms of our
contracts with all of our
customers and partners is
knowledge you have that is genuinely
proprietary to you
we will respect that we'll make sure
that it's marked as proprietary to you
in the psych knowledge base no one other
than you will be able to see it if you
don't want them to and it won't be used
in inferences other than
for you and so on however any knowledge
which is necessary
in building any applications for you and
with you
which is publicly available general
human knowledge
is not going to be proprietary it's
going to just become part of the normal
psych knowledge base and it will be
openly available to everyone who has
access to psych so that's an important
constraint that we never went back on
even when we
got pushback from companies which we
often did who wanted to claim that
almost everything they were telling us
was proprietary
so
so there's a line between very domain
specific company specific stuff
and the general knowledge that comes
from that
yes or if you imagine say it's an oil
company there are things which they
would expect
any new petroleum engineer they hired to
already know
and it's not okay for them to consider
that that is proprietary and there
sometimes the company will say well
we're the first ones to pay you to
represent that in psych
and our attitude is some polite form
tough
the deal is this take it or leave it and
in a few cases they've left it in most
cases um they'll they'll see our point
of view and take it because that's how
we've built the psych system
by uh essentially tacking with the
funding wins
where people would fund a project and
half of it would be general knowledge
that would stay permanently as part of
psychics so always with these
partnerships it's not like a distraction
from the main psych development it's uh
it's a supportive a small distraction
it's a small but it's not a complete one
so you're adding to the knowledge base
yes absolutely and we try to stay away
from um projects
uh that would not have that property um
so
let me go back and talk about open psych
for a second so
i've had a lot of trouble
expressing convincing
other ai researchers
how important it is
to use an expressive representation
language like we do this higher order
logic
rather than just using some triple store
knowledge graph type representation
and
so
as an attempt to show them
why they needed something more
we said oh well we'll represent
this unimportant
projection or shadow or subset of psych
that just happens to be
the simple binary relations the relation
argument one argument two triples and so
on and
then you'll see
how much more useful it is if you had
the entire psych system so it's all well
and good to have the taxonomic relations
terms like person and night and sleep
and bed and house and eyes
and and so on but
think about how much more useful it
would be if you also had all the rules
of thumb about those things like people
sleep at night they sleep lying down
they sleep with their eyes closed they
usually sleep in beds in our country
they sleep for hours at a time they can
be woken up they don't like being woken
up and so on and so on so it's that
massive amount of knowledge which is not
part of open psych and we thought that
all the researchers would then
immediately immediately say oh my god of
course we need the other 90 that you're
not giving us let's partner and license
psych so that we can use it in our
research but instead
what people said is oh even the bit
you've released is so much better than
anything we had we'll just make do with
this
yeah and so if you look there are a lot
of robotics companies today for example
which use open psych as their
fundamental ontology um and in some
sense the whole world missed the point
of open psych and we were doing it to
show people why that's not really what
they wanted and too many people thought
somehow that this was psych or that this
was in fact good enough for them and
they never even bother coming
coming to us to get access to the full
psych but there's there's two parts to
open psych so one is convincing people
an idea on the power of this general
kind of representation of knowledge
and the value that you hold and having
acquired that knowledge and built it and
continue to build it and the other is
the code base this is the code
side of it
so
my sense of the code base that cycle
psyc is operating with i mean
it has the technical debt
of the three decades plus right this is
the exact same problem that google had
to deal with with the early version of
tensorflow it's still dealing with that
they had to
basically break
uh compatibility with the past several
times
and that's only over a period of a
couple years
but they i think successfully opened up
this very risky very gutsy move to open
up tensorflow
and then pie torch on the facebook side
and what you see is there's a magic
place where you can find a community
where you can develop a community
that builds on on the system
without
taking away any of not any but most of
the value
so most of the value that google has is
still at google most the value that
facebook has still facebook even though
some of this major machine learning
tooling is released into the open
my question is
not so much in the knowledge which is
also a big part of open psych
but all the different kinds of tooling
so the
there's the kind of all the kinds of
stuff you can do on the knowledge graph
knowledge base whatever we call it
there's the inference
engines so there there could be some
that probably are a bunch of proprietary
stuff you want to kind of keep secret
and there's probably some stuff you can
open up completely and then let the
community build up enough community
where they develop stuff on top of it
yes there will be those publications and
academic work and all that kind of stuff
and uh and also the tooling of adding to
the knowledge base right like developing
you know there's an incredible amount
like there's so many people that are
just really good at this kind of stuff
in the open source community so my
question for you is like have you
struggled with this kind of idea
that you have so much value in your
company already you've developed so many
good things you have clients that really
value your relationships and then
there's this dormant giant open source
community that as far as i know you're
not utilizing
is
there there's so many things to say
there but
there could be magic
moments where the community builds up
large enough
to where
the artificial intelligence field that
is currently 99.9 machine learning
is dominated by machine learning
has a phase shift towards like
uh or at least in part towards more like
what you might call symbolic ai this
whole place
where psych
is like at the center of
and then as you know that requires a
little bit leap of faith because you're
now surfing and there'll be obviously
competitors that will pop up and start
making you nervous
and all that kind of stuff so do you
think about the space of open sourcing
some parts not others
how to leverage the community
all those kinds of things that's a good
question and i think you phrased it the
right way which is
we're constantly struggling with the
question of
what to open source what to make public
what to even publicly talk about right
um and
it's
there are
enormous pluses and minuses
to every
alternative
and it's very much like negotiating a
very treacherous path
part partly the analogy is like if you
slip
you could make a fatal mistake
give away something which essentially
kills you or fail to give away something
which um
failing to give it away um hurts you and
so on
so it is a it is a very tough
tough question
usually what we have done with
people who approached us to
collaborate on research is to say we
will
make available to you the entire
knowledge base
and
executable copies of all of the code
but
only very very limited
source code access if you have some idea
for how you might improve something or
work with us on something so let me also
get back to one of the very very first
things we talked about here
which was
separating the question of how could you
get a computer to do this at all versus
how could you get a computer to do this
efficiently enough in real time
and so
one of the
early lessons we learned
was that we had to separate
the epistemological problem of what
should the system know
separate that from the heuristic problem
of how can the system reason efficiently
with what it knows
and so
instead of trying to
pick
one representation language which was
the sweet spot or the best trade-off
point between expressiveness
of the language and efficiency of the
language if you had to pick one
knowledge graphs would probably be
associative triples would probably be
about the best you could do and that's
why we started there
but
after a few years we realized that what
we could do is we could split this and
we could have one
nice clean epistemological level
language which is this higher order
logic
and we could have one or more grubby
but efficient
heuristic level modules
that opportunistically
would say oh i can make progress on what
you're trying to do over here i have a
special method that will
contribute a little bit toward a
solution and so for some subset of
that exactly so by now we have over a
thousand of these heuristic level
modules and they function as a kind of
community of agents
and there's one of them which is a
general theorem prover and
in theory
that's the only one you need but in
practice it always takes so long
that you never want to call on it
you always want these other agents to
very efficiently reason through it it's
sort of like if you're balancing a
chemical equation you could go back to
first principles but in fact there are
algorithms which are vastly more
efficient or if you're trying to solve a
quadratic equation you could go back to
first principles of mathematics
but
it's much better to simply recognize
that this is a quadratic equation and
apply the binomial formula and snap you
get your answer right away and so on so
think of these as like a thousand little
experts that are all looking at
everything the site gets asked and
looking at everything that every other
little agent has contributed almost like
notes on a blackboard notes on a
a whiteboard
and
making additional notes when they think
they can be helpful and gradually that
community of agents
gets an answer to your question gets a
solution to your problem and if we ever
come up in a domain application where
psyc is getting the right answer but
taking too long
then
what we'll often do is talk to one of
the human experts and say
here's the the set of reasoning steps
that psych went through you can see why
it took it a long time to get the answer
how is it that you were able to answer
that question in two seconds and
occasionally you'll get an expert who
just says well i just know it i just was
able to do it or something and then you
don't talk to them anymore but sometimes
you'll get an expert who says um well
let me introspect on that yes here is a
special representation we use
just for
aqueous chemistry equations or here's a
special representation and a special
technique which we can now apply to
things in this special representation
and so on and then you add that as the
thousand and first
hl heuristic level module
and from then on
in any application if it ever comes up
again it'll be able to contribute and so
on so that that's pretty much one of the
main ways in which
psych has recouped this lost efficiency
a second important way is meta reasoning
so
you can speed things up by
focusing on removing knowledge from the
system until all it has left is like
minimal knowledge needed to but that's
the wrong thing to do right that would
be like in a human extra painting part
of their brain or something that's
really bad so instead what you want to
do is give it meta-level advice tactical
and strategic advice that enables it to
reason about
what kind of knowledge is going to be
relevant to this problem what kind of
tactics are going to be good to take in
trying to attack this problem when is it
time to start trying to prove the
negation of this thing because i'm
knocking myself out trying to prove it's
true and maybe it's false and if i just
spend a minute i can see that it's false
or something so so it's like dynamically
pruning the the graph to to only like
based on the particular thing you're
trying to
infer yes and so by now
we have about 150
of these sort of like breakthrough ideas
that have led to dramatic speed ups
in the inference process you know where
one of them was this el hl split and
lots of hl modules another one was using
meta and meta-meta-level reasoning
to reason about the reasoning that's
going on and so on um and you know 150
breakthroughs may sound like a lot but
you know if you divide by 37 years it's
not as impressive
so there's these kind of heuristic
modules that really help improve the the
inference
you